welcome to this video I'm playing bacon
butty FM Marcus ha way yeah I some a
pretty good FM from the UM from the UK
he plays a scotch converter wow this is
a not a very good opening I hope I can
can show again show why ok jazzing that
people still play that stuff ah is it g5
here I cannot remember or is it 95 I
think it's only g5 if why it has taken
on g ade and here it is somewhat
different but what is it
yeah this is one of those openings it's
really not good but refuted over the
board is a different different different
matter
and tween f6 I can remember really can't
remember okay queen of six in mighty
group legs and b7 hangs okay i can i can
take on f3 why it's difficult to
evaluate yeah okay well i think g5 has a
drawback maybe bishop age five I really
can't remember I can't remember anyway I
need to play a move now it's always
annoying and them playing a nonsense
opening but difficult to refute opening
okay so he went this you played that
very quickly Knight a5 Queen a for just
about hordes how do i play here maybe
just he and night 95 is also ok but
let's do this try to activate the Queen
amazing okay hmm what I can never be
good ready right but ok let's see how to
do this 95
f3 is hanging so i guess i have to go
rugby 81 d3 i can't start with d3
actually and that that cannot be bad
really so the rookie move I guess it's
difficult otherwise I have to move that
Queen I want to move the Queen and the
vibe yes and now Queen f6 I guess or is
that something better Queen age 4 is
also an attractive move Queen f6 look
strong though where's the screen going
after c6 nowhere to ecig so maybe I do
this and threaten c6 to trap the Queen
and i'm sure i've been checking f3 oh
I'm down 21 22 and yeah ok cool ok if
you take so much time even the even
complete nonsense can be very dangerous
like this I mean that would be a cool
position to have an a in a long time
control game I can basically choose how
to win probably if you have some time
one minutes is a bit can camp can be
tricky
I take f3 has the screen f5 at the end
to trade queens it's a very very
annoying idea i also had c6 in this
position that was maybe just better
after queen bee three I wouldn't have
needed to retreat that Bishop probably
that was was a lot stronger I mean it's
still not quite clear what you should
play with p 5 ok and queen you six
probably I don't know we are trying to
try to trade Queens time morning
yeah let's avoid that 50-something
seconds that's the biggest issue really
I know that's it's already you should be
dead already dad dad dad and it didn't
manage nice a very resourceful tech
Tichenor some huge deficits in many
errors of the game that is technically
super dangerous I know from back in the
chest cube days
I it's still good still a good position
but the problem is yeah they said it
should have been over a long time ago
can can hardly move anything so let's go
here
anything better maybe not I guess so
Jake see 50 yeah maybe his pawns get
dangerous on the Sun always got two of
them oh I didn't didn't really see that
one now ah that sets a frustrating game
now I got 10 seconds and probably the
position is isn't good anymore Oh God
yeah I know the story it's against this
guy I basically have winning positions
almost every game but I keep spoiling
those by playing tactically bad yeah
okay come on black resigns now that that
will be very frustrating that whole
opening line is just just absolutely bad
for white it's it's just bad bad bad bet
the thing is what do I have to play in
this was the real promise spend so much
time here I know that I know this thing
this is this is this is excellent for
black and known for a very long time but
he played this and ok it seems that the
engine gives taking 1230 I don't know I
really don't know yeah it cost it costs
too much time Queen B seven is immensely
immensely cheeky I mean I cannot believe
in that at all that you can grab another
porn while having this this this crap of
development and everything is weak and
so on so okay so I'm okay up to here I
mean okay as in winning but I can of
course improve from here that that was a
move that was influenced already you
with the time situation as i said
already during the game I could have
done this and I don't need to retreat as
the rook is spinning kini seven some
this is one winning possibility why do I
have to go to 87 by the way let me try
to figure that out if you take here is
this Queen D 1 yeah
we add but works so i have to have to
prepare that now you can barely move any
of these pieces are okay but that also
applied to the to the actual game b5 was
also we had but anyway queen is six g6 I
ok it's it's it's all minus 2 and
everything but still can't screw it up
oh where from I have Quincy one I didn't
really I didn't really see that move ok
I mean I saw the move but I thought yes
at four and I didn't really see where to
go with that night but the computer is
just mercilessly pointing out that this
is of course booking and black is
winning again now this is the problem
you have to spot those things then I'm
just technically sometimes hard to a nap
to do that you know this is this is
basically winning there's nothing
nothing you can do ok this is still good
hook like according to the comp but it's
ok now i have g4 at age five ok well i
only have a couple of seconds to have it
ok maybe maybe we this is again as rook
c1 and that activates them immensely so
it seems that just playing it slowly is
also just winning like minus two they
are kept it here well I have no time I
have no time rupee eight is better and
even hear it so it's still draw a play
correctly but let's not the point the
point is that that is an unplayable
opening that I should punish and I
didn't manage because I made too many
technical mistakes I mean he made many
many vend rather obviously bad moves but
you can recognize that they're bad um
but to refute them in
in a convincing fashion is a different
matter that's important to understand if
you have a good strategic understanding
you don't really you see that their
moves are bad you are Queen B 7 and so
on that's just bad but refuting it is a
different kind of animal and in those
limited times as simple as sometimes
simply fail to see the right
continuations from a purely technical
point of view that doesn't change the
the valuation that that they played
badly or that those moves have to be
pointed out the same time I have to
point out and I do um how I feel to
convert it yeah those moves that that
are just bad like like this is not good
c6 is stronger okay well some things are
difficult to see with the time but some
some things I really could have seen
Quincy one okay that's something that
you hear that your casa we'll see if you
have some time but with no time the
thing is he can barely move any of his
pieces something and I know what what is
play he loses he loses the house iam I
mean on the dark squares white is
completely busted yeah okay that's
difficult yeah this is this is what I'm
saying a musical all the time and you
can make tons of strategic mistakes if
you play technically very alert you can
save many games and all all the nice
things really lead to nowhere if you are
if you don't convert it like I fail to
do in this game now this is this kind of
players from what is going to fail in a
classical time control game basically
all the time but in blitz if the
opponent is technically week like I am
here in this game on you can get away
with many things as we have witnessed
okay thanks for watching